rajasthan in northern india
temperatures here regularly soar above
45 degrees celsius and the heat waves
are getting longer
a consequence of climate change says
shiyam sunder gianni
for years he's been observing how the
extreme conditions have caused the
expansion of deserts
scarcity of water is a big concern of
desert because we don't have ground
water because it is in very depth and
also
not good in quality it is not usable and
as far as rain is concerned
every year we
receive minimum rainfall in this area
she and zunda gianni didn't want to sit
back and do nothing
so in his spare time
he travels to villages to give away free
saplings of ancient indigenous fruit
trees
these plants can thrive in the harsh
climate
today he's visiting the school at
banduran village
he urges the villagers to take care of
the trees so that they grow to provide
shade and fruit
work starts after plantations but
generally people consider that
when we did plantation it's over but we
we say that
now our responsibility starts from that
point so i requested them to consider
that now our responsibility has
increased and we have to grow all
saplings as a green member of emily
these trees will give us fresh air to
breathe and fruit to eat
we've learned that trees need to be
treated as members of our family only
then can they save our planet
today bandaran villagers are also being
given a tree each to take home once
planted they're watered with waste water
shiems under gianni named his
organization familial forestry after the
idea it was founded on
it all started back in 2003 when shiyam
sunder gianni was a young sociology
professor working at a college in
the few trees on the campus grounds were
almost dead
along with the students he saved them
and replaced them with saplings
from then on the students cared for the
trees the next step came a few years ago
in 2013 we started
development of institutional forest and
we started plantation over there you can
see this is a six sector of land and
having more than three thousand trees of
uh more than one hundred 100 different
varieties it is most diverse
institutional forest in any educational
institute of rajasthan
pays for the seedlings out of his own
pocket he often ends up spending a large
portion of his salary
while his peers focus on advancing their
careers he invests his time and energy
in familial forestry
the dedication sometimes makes things
hard for his wife cavita
she often has to look after their two
daughters alone
money is often tight at the end of the
month
i see people with similar jobs living
luxurious lives
they celebrate their children's
birthdays in restaurants drive big cars
have their own houses
actually
but the sacrifice isn't in vain shiam
sunder giani has planted more than three
million seedlings in the villages of
rajasthan in recent years for a long
time his commitment and efforts went
unnoticed by the public and authorities
but things changed this year since june
the media have been turning up at the
tree planting wanting interviews the
familial forestry was recognized with
the land for life award by a u.n
organization that fights to prevent
desertification worldwide the yuban ccd
i've seen many activities that you
donate a tree and then somebody else
takes care of the tree on your behalf
but the idea of familiar forestry is by
seeing a tree as a member of the family
you will cultivate
the care for the tree therefore the
survival rate of the trees in the region
where familial forestry planted
is significant significantly higher
he's hoping the award will attract
donors and financial support he sees the
indigenous fruit trees as crucial to
stop arid desert areas expanding and
keeping villagers from malnutrition
and he points out yet another benefit
his work brings
fruit bearing trees attracts
biodiversity it increases biodiversity
also because
these trees attract butterflies small
insects pollinators even birds
so by this way we can increase and we
can
uh
protect our biodiversity also
sheam sunder gianni has another idea
that he's dreamt of for a long time
planting trees along roadsides in
india's sprawling cities where space is
scarce
urban populations are in need of clean
air and vitamin packed fruit as well